[Musique]
c'est l'artiste kenji girac qui lancera
la 34e édition de l'estivale le vendredi
17 septembre ce festival de musique
défend la chanson francophone et c'est
au théâtre de poissy qu aura lieu ce
premier concert puisque cette année la
ville de saint-germain-en-laye n'a pas
souhaité renouveler son partenariat avec
le festival ce sera donc trois villes
yvelinoise qui accueilleront des
spectacles beaucoup sont sur le théâtre
de poissy qui est le nouveau lieu
central on va dire mais donc il ya aussi
des concerts rocket iii
opecst et au sax hr cette édition 2021
sera marquée par plusieurs temps forts
claudio capéo dimanche 26 septembre à
20h30 au théâtre de poissy il viendra
chanter ses plus grands tubes mais aussi
des chansons de son nouvel album seront
aussi de la fête trois cafés gourmands
hr vendredi 1er octobre ils
interpréteront notamment leur tube qui
les a fait connaître à nos souvenirs
le samedi 18 septembre un concert
gratuit sera également proposée de façon
assez exceptionnelle cette année on va
aussi recevoir catherine ringer qui
vient chanter les rita mitsouko et on va
l'accueillir au moment des journées
européennes du patrimoine à poissy dans
le parc meissonnier le festival se
clôturera par carla bruni qui chantera
ses dernières chansons écrites l'année
dernière au théâtre de poissy dimanche 3
octobre à 20h30 les organisateurs
attendent 30000 visiteurs durant les
deux semaines